[Music]
I'm here at stitches and I hope you're
speaking about a political staff data's
- well the beautiful rundown of what
okay so they do everyone know about we
talking about today
first I'll talk a bit about what we do
so what stitch fix doesn't company
actually does give you some context as
to what the data scientists are into two
of them the slipper engineer supporting
the data scientist - I'll then talk a
bit about Kali pottery and particularly
the algorithms in analytic esteem which
encapsulated stay on platform and the
data scientist and then I'll speak about
what it is that the platform does and
how we try to serve the data scientist
that we support and I call this
transforming the way the scientists do
with a love which is almost a joke that
will make sounds like previous lives
so what gave you we have a business
where we sell clothing and then we
actually focus a lot on your customer
experience those nutterman forms the
data we end up having so we saw all okay
we have been splitting and women funding
to Maternity Clothing plus-sized
clothing
those are yes so they're all their
business lines and so what this means
when I say that we saw something and
somehow we use a lot of technology that
what we're trying to do is a really
intense form of personalization of what
people wear is extremely personal and it
tends to be a real lot of people express
themselves or alternatively don't I have
lots of friends that wear all black or
like where I'll black because they want
to just not make decisions
when I was getting dressed today I was
thinking about audience here what it is
they want to express for example this is
talk I actually gave on Friday as well
at Facebook's women in analytics
conference Olivia no platform trap and
there's oh I'm going to be provided with
this really large group of amazing women
that do data science and analytics and
data engineering I think with this group
it can be a little fancier and a little
edgier think about this audience erupts
like you know what pretty casual pretty
laid-back how much easier than genies
kind of place but when I present I kind
of like to go pretty hard enough
evidence off because I can and I feel
like I successfully accomplished what I
wanted in my outfit today because one of
my co-workers saw me it's like oh you
look ready to run through a field of
flowers which is exactly what I was
going for so really I mean I do
certainly think about Logan in terms of
solvents brushing and so doing
personalization for plugged into
something that does be personal this
personalization late apply but also very
emotional and so what this looks like a
medium personalization for a person that
is that it is made of order on stitch
basis that they go to our website you
may sign up part of signing up is
filling out a survey the survey has
information about basic things like your
size your age also about your
preferences and clothing preferences and
material preferences and colors and
patterns and we use this information
then after you say send me a fix to give
you to a personal stylist this personal
stylist picks out clothing for you this
clothing goes into a box that gets
mailed to you you try it on at home you
can poke you like the email back what
you don't and you check out online
giving us feedback on what it is that
you can do or do not like about those
items
so in our men's line for example we
collect a ton of information about fit
and there's actually a lot more than the
stitch fix does other than clothing
personalization other parts of our
business so a really interesting example
is that when you give us information
about to fit in our men's clothing huge
amount of our men's clothing business is
exclusive brands which means meanings
back poking ourselves so we have us this
feedback loop of we make some clothing
with certain materials and certain cuts
certain styles colors we try to sell it
to people we see if they want to buy it
and if they don't we try to collect
granular feedback on what works or
doesn't and what we found when we
originally launched our men lines over
our cuts for two foxy
so not everyone appreciated how our
shirts were cut a lot of this will
terrific things like that give us a lot
of information to then go back and
correct the clothing that were actually
maybe even selling and the changes that
we make try to be very positive prior
sales so there's a ton of different ways
that data and using data fits into this
business model so we sell it both dating
we have to buy clothing get to by coding
six months in advance
we need to predict how much we're gonna
sell and at a very quickly growing
company if you look at our revenue
numbers of the last few years it's huge
changes and they're very quickly growing
from being able to accurately predict
how much we think we're gonna sell is
difficult and split that amongst
business lines and beyond that's so many
ones sizes and styles and what screw
items we need we have a lot of data
scientists that work on a variety of
properties so let me describe to you how
it is organized all these in scientists
also it's probably
as I mentioned data science is part of
the algorithm as part of algorithms and
analytics was an organization we have a
c-level executive that reports to
Katrina Lee seems Eric Wilson its color
and shape algorithms officer and
underneath ins there are two sections of
algorithms and analyze one is what
you're this data scientist so we have in
the data science category data
scientists are organized by vertical and
a describer so we have to get assigned
it's working on styling so most people
they think of data scientists eventually
oh yes of course they need to recommend
they have these two people true we need
to recognize I know two people but
beyond that we actually have an internal
application that we show to our personal
stylists and these personal stylists
will use this information showing than
the recommendations and have different
algorithms ready fish that show up of
what people might like or not like
but beyond that we also want to sort of
experiment on stylist behavior what
information should we show stylist and
make the best decisions how do we
organize it we have operations so we buy
clothing and ascended people in the mail
which means that we have warehouses that
we need to store this clothing and mail
or other and this is the actual thing is
probably whenever the most fascinating
problems and doing really efficient
operations with the amount of clothing
that we have and the warehouses that we
have when you join the stitch biggest on
the second day in the morning you get to
tour a warehouse and see how things
happens inside of the warehouse and I
have never seen an assault and hashmap
implemented in real life but it is
we have the client team is all about
accumulating new clients making sure we
have clients in the long term and we
have this horizontal data science team
which i think is which is new I think a
very interesting scheme and I will speak
a bit about that later because they have
a interesting sub team which I think
fills a gap that has come about because
of the way we've decided to organize
projects inside of data science which is
a lot of what I'll talk about here so a
bunch of data scientists doing all
different kinds of work different
verticals styling office client but all
of these verticals have overlapping
that's in the business and they need to
be able to communicate mclubbe
collaborate with one another then they
have data for architect hang it off to
the side this is the team that I love us
and we basically trying to figure out
how to help these data spy just as much
as possible but what that means really
has to be thought in the context of how
we structure our projects and how we
motivate people though our workers
products so one of the things I really
really enjoy about working a snitch base
is that we have a huge emphasis on
autonomy and ownership of projects where
particularly with a particularly with
our data scientists we want them to own
a project and abandoned it's their
responsibility to partner with their
business partners so that they were
violently inside of leadership if
they're working in merchandise planning
and working with the buyers and
merchandise figure out the requirements
for a project figure out how they figure
out what but it interface between them
and the business looks like and to build
a model and iterate on it and any way
that you need to do so the downstream
impact of that on the way data platform
functions is first we don't write ETL or
the data scientist there's a pretty
popular blog post at J paddock Jeff
I wrote so I'm going to here read
engineer should not read et al yeah so
see like order of the room and it's I
think a completely fascinating blog post
in which he emphasizes data scientists
feeling ownership over their projects
but also a structure in which engineers
that are building tools for data
scientists don't feel like they have no
creative output or no creative outlet in
our work for them to so when data
engineers are working just on building
pipelines and handing them off to
someone else you kind of lose the Tata
meter right and yet you have this
friction of having made decisions about
what happens to the data along the way
and then you give it to a data scientist
to do the fun stuff with and I did it
and it worked both sides of being a
dedicated engineering and doing
mathematical model and in the science
work
I think the mathematical model modeling
part is really creative and fun but I
also think that they're doing activity
you really need to have a good handle
what happened to the data along the way
and so I I appreciated this ownership
model where David scientists are meant
to own things they build an antenna so
let's compare this to what we see in
other companies a typical data science
department has a few components there is
obviously data scientists there are did
engineers that are building the pipeline
and making sure that data goes from some
working in format so maybe from the data
data systems that are supporting an
application into a data warehouse and
then building derived tables off of that
their assignments that are building
their models and trying to optimize some
sort of process and then there's
software engineers that take these
models and deploy up
and at the bottom of that I did it
infrastructure engineers to make sure
all the systems continue to be alive to
you to work the Dan mentioned I worked a
clatter for a while and one of the
things that makes it there was I would
consult with our really big fortune 500
international huge companies about their
data science teams how they're working
how they're organized and frequently go
in there you ask so what's going well
what's going wrong tell me all about how
things are working here and a really
really common pattern that resulted in
big complaints was this process of the
handoff between data scientists and
people with white walls so often what I
would see is a data science we build a
extremely accurate you and convoluted
model they would then go to a software
engineering team and say okay it's done
it's ready here you go just go you know
put it in production
whatever that means his software
engineers would get this model perhaps
it is not the best commented perhaps it
is not the best documented and it would
take months to get a model from
something that was written in Python or
are really into some language that is
part of a production experience system
this is a little something it becomes
pretty obvious to executives that are
watching this system now why is it
taking so long to get our new assistant
up so
there's an alternative way to think
about what's happening we're taking all
of these different types of roles so
they're trying to make a new
recommendation system for example our
new recommendation model all of these
rules have to work together to provide
this one to get internet capability and
I'm going talking to the executive and
then say well I know that I said I would
deliver this capability to business its
new recommendation system in three
months why did it take nine quietens
don't have that and realistically they
actually have attention capabilities
that they would like to be delivering to
the business or responsibility for
continually delivering the business and
what ends up being really challenging
here that we get many rolls spread
across many capabilities and there's a
lot of interaction and coordination that
needs to happen between all of them so
this results in a lot of the union's a
lot of people started sitting down kind
of transfer information between each
other and I think this is a sign of if
this was truly a system that involvement
humans that's a bad API design but that
I think this is a challenging aspect of
this type of organization so there's a
different way that we can organ it's you
can think about
data-driven capabilities being
completely owned and driven by data
scientist which is what we do in stitch
fix so what we have is a bunch of
different capabilities that we want to
provide the business this could be a
client this could be a merchandising
this could be an autonomous team and we
have the data scientist or teams of data
scientist own these capabilities and
engineer processing to the deployment
models so they need on the
implementation of the models is might be
a DTL type lie that means to run
regularly plus the service that consumes
that end of that data they own the
coordination of the business which
announces her product management skills
and production support asterisk sort of
so that's great digits like this do
everything and where did that engineers
go alright I still have a job so what do
I do and what does that word on the day
platform team to do well data scientists
and a special Isaac better thing and
they're gonna provide the business
they're going to provide up into the new
recommendation honor those you can steal
by our site and application David up
form engineer has become a specialized
by function by the types of services
utilities we're going to provide it as
scientists so we build infrastructure
what kind of infrastructure is believe
for us here I like to think of it a
scientist as black boxes thank you
put it in dashboards and services come
out so I can try to break down this
workflow very detailed workflow into
what sort of services we currently
provide I'll do my best to focus on
things that exist and our fully
functioning in production with the one
caveat that I'm going to talk about a
thing that I think is really interesting
is long they have project funds in
staging right now and they like to put
this idea out there to hear what people
think about it we're just a bit so we
need to transport data right I said that
the algorithms department has a c-level
executive dirt this is fascinating
because we also this engineering team
right there ones producing the data and
measurements about our customers
certainly about operations at our
warehouse they're going and we need to
actually get the data from them so is
in the state of transport box we consume
data from engineering things like many
snapshots of their databases you also
keep a copy Cuba which was shot to
listen the back excuse and amazing
platform engineering substance and she
has guiding everyone to move to
Cocteau's
as a way to have the author Christine
consume messages off of our engineering
teams rabbitmq
so we have ways of capturing data from
engineering landing them into core
tables that data scientist that it
consumed so a lot of the ETL jobs that
data scientists own they're not truly
only minute and right they're not
grabbing the data from engineering it's
our responsibility to make sure that
this data ends up in a place that data's
life is worth close to that rely on so
there's quite a few ETL that saying once
this may lead snapshot glands broad
let's work look so great then if I just
have to they'll both of them and then
they did this like a magical black box
thing right and I would like to think
that they spent all their time in and
I'm dreaming and writing on chalkboard
realistically there's a lot more and any
creative things to happen so I need be
greedy and I of course may netf the
money every did a scientist favorite
complain great have great ideas and I
need to actually go make computers
implement them so in order for us to
allow data scientists to really reliably
define ETL jobs run the people at our
infrastructure we had to build fooling
around
and when I say our infrastructure I of
course mean W us here is AWS yeah yeah I
just pulled away by how many how much
infrastructure but it's shifted on to
AWS so we don't just say data scientists
here's a here's an account also the
billing go have fun right this would be
I think an unpleasant experience for
most data scientists so what we've done
instead is try to provide some ice or
interfaces particularly around the logic
and care service for defining where jobs
are going to run and what environments
they run so you have two systems bit one
called flotilla which this is not gonna
go through flotilla it's not proper
about but those are miss Litella
a lot it's really a nice interface for
UCS and it allows our data scientist to
go to a web UI special file command they
want to run one thirty ten launches and
job starts
specify what image then why use and
that's what dependencies need to be
available in their environment a fair
number of are they designed for some
models that require pretty good call
that heavy-duty libraries that if you
installed them every time that would be
quite a pain so we needed to provide
also since your tooling to allow you to
scientists to define images that have
the libraries that they need to baked in
and so that is true
Perl is a way to in a git repo define
what define some files and some
libraries that can you install and then
from that be able to build allies docker
images and rpm
so relatively relatively low-level hey I
need you to run this thing is yes
infrastructure for data scientists but
the toilet itself is actually pretty
easy to interface with it and flip
tailgate opens lost and I think it's a
nice nice lovely interface I'd recommend
checking it out it's about flotilla - at
OS it looks like this you give your foot
to lift up your name
neither the television you use specify
some answers more that you can see
online and a blog post written about
this so I think that's pretty ready to
sign just quite a bit of relatively low
level they need to be able to to use the
computer infrastructure not run their
jobs in their laptops right the last
thing you want to find out what someone
has worked there for a while built a
bunch of models it was about to me for
another job is that all of their TTL
pipelines have been running on their
laptop right so we kind of avoid bad but
there is also another level of thinking
about what they decide to start doing
inside of this black box and what some
of their challenges are I don't think
the only challenge is how do you run
this container uneasy aside you make
sure to do is never able to do I think
that it's really really hard to make it
in a science reproducible collaborative
and accurate and I again I get the
opportunity to work with such great
people they work with Hilary Parker and
she works on the staff and the styling
organization and she has brought a great
paper and he would give a series of
talks about the communit analysis
development and so it's very much
focused around how does an individual
data scientist use tools that integrate
that those tools into their workflow to
make more reproducible after a curing a
collaborative analysis I think that this
is in fact one thing
to think about a very challenging crawl
but from my point of view I want to
think about it from the perspective of a
per engineer so how how can a platform
provide tools it is I just make their
work more reproducible accurate and
collaborative well we didn't jump on the
line what people are doing inside that
black box kind of I think that people
are making artifacts so a data scientist
needs to do some work this is an
elevated line so may need to be multiple
little jobs stitched together or a
sequel query followed by some spark and
what comes out at the end our models or
data and these artifacts it would be
wonderful if we had a way to think about
hurting them so you can imagine them and
now looking at the slide in which of the
deities geek make you know what version
and not PDF they did not think about the
export it but you can imagine that in
making new tables and defying these ETS
and having this artifact that is a data
output that we have first a price
preference table so this prick price
preference table you can imagine that
same part of our styling survey is a
client how much do you prefer to spend
on glasses a client tells us they prefer
to spend $75 on glasses and then
something to scientist down the line has
an ETL pipe I think they're responsible
for that's push the label our clients as
high price point or not so do these
people want slightly more expensive
things where and let's say two months
ago the definition it was if it's less
than $100 then it's not a high price
point and so it will record that in some
derived table somewhere
now let's say we run this again today
and the outfit says actually they are
high price point we see a new client
with the same client ID now two months
in the future they're now a high price
point it's hard for us to tell and
untangle if what happened was the data
changed or the definition used to define
the new data change and so I think that
there's a lot of opportunity in bottle
building and they have a process
building to think really clearly about
versioning and understanding how
computation changes over time and the
reason that I become concerned about
things like this let's say we have all
of these individual data scientists
working on their projects they're
earning their capability end-to-end but
let's say that one of their models it
would be really useful to own to consume
in that model the output of another one
consume it they'll go to another model
often the great idea
can have useful information caption in
it but if that other model changes in
time and it could change in a variety of
ways some inconsequential some very
consequential that is the data scientist
that's built in small and consuming it
should have some way of knowing that in
some way I'm already on that change even
in a less complicated world you can
imagine a dashboard made for c-level
executives where a certain number is
being reported and that number of some
of these changes and then they ask black
what happened here is this growth lucky
and the fundamental in the business or
is this reflecting some strange artifact
of data and it being able to answer that
question and untangle that quickly it is
extremely hard or not thinking about
this room lineage of how details are
changing over time so this is the pet
project currently in staging not fully
for
yet that is my team this year since your
interests align so if you're interested
in talking more about this and other
sports then how did you find this tiny
later helping I mean later it's happy
hour I guess so fun day there so there
were of course now that we have these
artifacts that they designed to submit
there's other things that they need to
do with them so one of these artifacts
is they need that force right so we do
and support really well a few things
around making natural rhythm playing
them in our infrastructure first I think
our tooling around shiny and it'll be
great
it's very easy to use a simple package
but one of our great dinners I mean
years is built to deploy your shiny
application it'll to use package package
up all the our dependencies that you
need and then it will deploy it either
to stay in staging or production Japan
already knew as you go and once it go
there it's visible inside inside of it
but if you need to make it visible to
other groups so to say you're a public
company
we need to use Foxconn fine and you need
to make sure that only the right people
are seeing the right things we have a
tool called the day light which allows
us to say here are the groups of people
configured through our du Helder after
one login system by their roles and it
was a lot of to see what and suddenly
it's publicly available internally our
network for people to see the right
dashboards they're allowed to see great
when it comes to services this is I
think extremely bad because so I'll
explain a challenge of doing and off of
models between data scientist engineers
in some situations that handoff is
really really hard to avoid so you can
imagine doing real time fraud detection
you probably want an engineer making
sure that you can meet the latency
requirements of a system like that
you're trying to do credit card
processing your charge of processing
you're looking for that data scientists
are perhaps not the right people to be
don't need a lot of your service if you
have really strict latency requirements
or you're at a huge scale and
improvement and some unity concerned
about you they're probably not do phone
design mental system in our situation
most of the services that we provide for
automated EDI consumption are working
with our internal tools so you can
imagine our internal styling up we have
recommendations that appear in that the
internal style apt is you can buy other
extent fix employees having a little bit
of latency not so bad also there's not a
huge number of the stylist cumulus
there's some you know not so many that
it even yeah it's the engineering
requirements are relatively light which
means we can really provide some useful
tools to allow you to scientists to
build simple servers so what we end up
doing and what I think every production
machine learning and service needs to do
is provide an environment that a wallop
you running provide a deployment
mechanism for storage the right
environment and then also it will allow
data assets so you can imagine there's
an easy alibi climate trans a model
parameters get written somewhere those
parameters need to be made available to
the service and it would be best if the
service were able to continually refresh
those parameters of the exchange so
let's say you have an a good job that
goes in your model you don't want to
read a buyer service just to get more
data so we need to be able to access the
data that results in them in an ETL job
and then we also need to provide a
regional API by reasonable API I mean
something that that's documented
something that can handle the throughput
that we have I say that there's not high
engineering requirements but also I
think if you let a data scientist build
a service on their own and maybe would
not have all of these features or if it
did that would be using four copies of
the last eight search summon on some
shady so we built the system called Cod
the SoCon really allows us to easily fit
into our service deployment
infrastructure and allow data scientists
to write a simple script that has all
our run script that specifies endpoints
these endpoints consume JSON and con
itself is written in Python 3 the
gentleman is consumed is matched to the
function signature that was associated
with that endpoint and we do things like
type checking when you're using tight
defensive Python 3 and then returns more
JSON and depending on what that JSON
this we can generate automated swagger
box for it and share those with our
engineering organization is so
integrated you guys that works very
smoothly and the piece that I think is
probably the most useful I think it did
a scientist given enough time in the
blast augmentation can build a web
server I think it is significantly
harder to cheaply reliably easily access
data that's a complicated question
ETL 5 lakhs and having a great web
service deployment and so this data
movement
system ends up being hugely useful we do
things like all parameters we also do
things like pre compute client features
the recommendation plan for example you
maybe don't want to go back in history
and do all the right joints to figure
out what a person was client feature
vector issues we're going and so we will
regenerate them look them into it you're
going to see the access and try to
because as simple as possible we're
pretty short tutorial and it is I just
love tutorial use that you know on that
of course we have monitoring fogging
contributing all things that may or may
not exist in the data scientist starts
good fermentation if we didn't set it up
for them already and this ends up being
extremely valuable and useful in order
to make sure engineering things a girl
lab old team and our services fail so we
get a great picture to be there and like
I said you know that's data scientist on
the same production and they own
production so it really means that they
get engaged simultaneously and we try to
express a contract with them that is is
a data scientist on that team's
responsibility to help triage a problem
which I think has one big benefit of
this is that if it's something they
already know about it
ETL pipeline a fail then they have more
context about what might be going on in
the system beyond that it's also useful
for that team to understand what is
working or not working and how
frequently does the students fail
because if it's something that is
specific about a man that their
application then it provides motivation
for them to simultaneously improve that
work on but platform teams we thought
were the development platforms unit is
there to pump key bug and actually make
sure the service is thought that
regularly as possible but we working
collaboration between the scientists
make sure that that happens
so I describe this this way that we
function how it organized obstructing
these twenty degree and a nice
self-serving question is what works well
and I think one of the things that works
really well about the wastage fixes
organize the way data scientists have a
project ownership is that I think people
mostly feel very engaged and satisfied
of their jobs they feel like they can do
their jobs in the way that they need to
as an ad hoc or engineer I certainly
feel that way I would really value
building some data sources for someone
else to do all the fun things with it I
feel like I'm trying to understand it's
time to support clean building our tools
without what are the challenging parts
of this sort of organization well that
what boats that I mentioned engineer
should not write ETL when I first read
it I was scandalized scandalized and
part of the reason was that I have seen
situations in which there were poorly
maintained data on us and it was a mess
it was all over the place and when I
heard this system described I was like
your data has got to be all over the
place how do you all collaborate and how
do all I can say to each other doing
even hot like how do you begin to you
think about we're basing this and this
is right then and point back to that
slide way at the beginning of the top so
long ago
where I said hey there's this horizontal
design is key I will talk about a sub
team on it I'm around the same time that
I joined a woman named Laura join and
she is now leading the analytics
engineering to you analytics engineering
is building a dimensionally model data
warehouse and they are unifying
solidifying
and just sort of providing core data
sources that are easier to use and a lot
of this ends up being formed isness
partners so we have a looker set up set
up on top of that now service of Carter
to your access to look at some data
scientist I think will end up using this
I'm sure the patterns of ideas that they
share around hey this is what a
dimension table is for example who he
really school and beneficial to entire
business yeah and when I read that blog
post Avenger not ready to yell
I immediately invited J Matt Jeff Nagisa
to be on an ETL panel of at a conference
and it was all organized because I
thought oh he was just such a rabble
rouser you sure you weren't gonna work
here I thought you were definitely never
gonna work so mad about that post so
that's really like to say about how we
[Applause]
won is this is evolved from the
personality available the data
scientists were just variable or was
this form of beauty first
second part is how those impact for
creating hiring is this specific kind of
it's like good for now sure so your
first question was this very diverse or
was it just the personnel available
this was very firmly rooted in Netflix's
culture
so Eric Wilson had an elegance analytics
and jeff- had a platform
Brad hey Herbert last day they all came
from Netflix and Netflix is very deep in
the economy of ownership you of the
world and so that definitely translated
immediately into how Eric Fred Gina you
wanted to to find how others and others
worked second question how does this now
impact the types of data scientists we
will look at it before it really depends
team magazines and when I say so I think
the original conception of autonomy and
ownership was an individual rooms acute
ability and that is not a very reliable
robust human system right we want teams
to all capabilities and maybe an
individual design implementation but we
want to location of understanding unit
ownership so that's one aspect of it I
think that transition from having an
individual on every capability to teams
owning it has turned into and hiring a
little bit a little bit more gray area
or you can go to consumer building this
team they're gonna like we're gonna
build it with one person that has
like high staff skills and not the
strong programming skills horrible build
it with someone who has built a lot of
production services there's just
absolutely charming up but like they're
not one of our PhD is in statistics you
don't understand
so I think that this is transition but
we still very much expect full stack
data scientist and definitely I think
people that are immediately successful
are ones that have had more experience
with any capabilities of them because
it's not only little I think the
challenging thing is that when we talk
about owning capabilities
it required aquatic management science
requires and a local sense and it
requires engineering sense but what
people actually do day-to-day like I've
been doing more inference and they're
running a bunch of AP tests melanoma
systems are they doing analysis for a
need understand so it's just actually
will appeal to me about all the business
partners those are all different skill
set so I think there's a lot of
opportunities for different tastes that
it is like I think there are different
types of the world but people that tend
to be successful to give you a bit more
experience and really excited about
autonomy and ownership or not yeah the
first thing I wanted to say that you
have a noble goal and anybody their core
principles are they sound and I know
it's not easy to set this up but it
seems that some businesses along lines
of my question isn't where the tiny
details of your implementation like for
example when you talk about data
scientist setting up the service does
this mean they define the API that
shouldn't be like interact with a
product that they defined like how it's
going to be cached or it did older like
pre-processing on meat when those like
devil in the details or all the guy that
runs in production are like data
scientist so expected to do all this yes
so I would say the assignments are
expected to on the ETL pipelines that
generate things that get served when it
comes to defining the AP is know what
who's interacting our engineering team
most probably it'll be a mix of the data
science team that engineering team that
they're integrating with the final goes
in that API and often this turns into
gets immunity
I think the producer and the consumer
come up with the contract that's
mutually okay and often someone from the
NATO platform team might be there to
help with the data science side or
they'll come to us and say hey this is
what we bought because this is good I
think that happens much more frequently
when we're doing things like we're
rewriting IDB testing system right now
and so that what a t-test even looks
like and how they were in engineering
that way ends up being subtle of Turkey
and he's more discussion and so often in
the platform will get integrated in
those conversations but we try to help
handoff and so maybe we're doing all set
up the system but anyone who's data
scientist by they're running their
experiments to be able to come on their
experiments without of us cutting it or
being run whatever trans Indians we
think about that the long-term
implications of trying to minimize
handoff between how do scientists
sanitation life partner that you can
spread your motors when they're of the
body or as far as most kind of ways of
trying to good or whatever versus it is
so all of all of our systems are built
on relatively open space I think JSON
communication maybe guys is pretty
standard for web services
I'm curious about the new holiday time
guarantee what do you need a business to
do you see on how you define what their
sofas yes they ready to go and they
right so the way that it's organized is
that kind of like the verticals we have
clients filing cops
there's from one engineer for each of
those are some people were hiring for
client and they are responsible for
taking the courts ables
and try to understand what record tables
lots of data scientists use and the
business needs from our business
partners that we've some reporting on
top of that figure out what the support
table should look like figure out what
the dimension should look like gravity
needs to be drive dimensions for
reporting and building those and so they
build out of you scale patterns and
we're hoping that their jaw the walls to
so that they have they communicate with
best practices are your best ETL
practice but what does eat a law
practice exist and so when I'm thinking
about how the system for traffic changes
and ETL is going to work
they're my best first customer right
like they're building four tables
they're extremely good at ETL and
engineering humans build a good at
building the model data schemas
analyzable data's came out and they end
up being good Justine's
and so every time I'm like oh and here's
dawn right ptl's well some of the Santa
Lotus engineering team which is to me
obviously relieved that we have that
like I think organization should have
have a sort of rigor around particles
they do report you don't like but it's
your question up though yeah great
we got time for one more question
related to some of that are they coming
to a full stack data scientists you find
that yeah I think it certainly problems
but only one person owns it
one of the things is a direction that
most teams are moving is thinking about
incentivizing teamwork on ownership I
think there was a common misconception
that the way they did got promoted is it
own more capabilities since we just like
slowly accumulated this thing where like
you're the only person that knows it and
that's a bad incentive structure for us
to have because then people individually
only things and so we're moving to a
world where there's more incentive and
professional development to own things
into teams and have that team be
responsible recorded and so I think
absolutely there are challenges if a
single person's capability in the
Olympic company who who had all this
expert knowledge about it right when you
do data analysis you into understanding
data the model isn't really into that
way and it's not something that's easily
transferable
right you can spend only writing just
something continuously writing about a
mom I don't think you can communicate
enough about it yeah so more important
or team encouragement of the ownership
those things definitely today were
working on
[Music]